Um, uh, so just to remind everyone, you know, when we talk about AML and we talk about outcomes,
we actually have two different, uh, classification systems now, right?
We have ELN 2022, which is how patients respond to intensive chemotherapy, but depending on
the treatments that we use, of course, you know, different mutations may predict for
different, um, outcomes based on the therapy being used.
And so the ELN 2024 is the first to try to, you know, talk about how patients will do
to lower intensive therapies.
And you'll notice IDH2 and IDH1 are now considered favorable risk, um, particularly IDH2 when
used with, with HMA venetoclax is, is quite favorable and IDH1, the asterisk is there
highlighting the fact that really, regardless of what other mutations are co-mutated with
the IDH1, they do quite well with AZA-IVO, the IDH1 inhibitor.
So just kind of as, as background, um, and then just to remind everyone also that, you
know, we talk about IDH mutations, but they're really not all the same.
Um, IDH2.
IDH2 is much more often kind of an early clonal mutation.
You can see that in the kind of the brown figure in the center.
Um, IDH1 is often, um, um, kind of happens a little bit later, although still is, uh,
earlier than the signaling mutations like RAS and FLT3 that come later.
Um, and then when it, it's a, it's a busy heat map, but it's just trying to highlight
the fact that the different mutations often have different co-occurring mutations.
So IDH2, R140 in particular has often NPM1 and FLT3 FLT3 co, uh, co-mutated alongside,
whereas IDH2 is much more common.
So IDH2, R172 is very different, right?
You see type 2, B-core, DNMT3A.
Very rarely will you have a FLT3 or an NPM1 and IDH1 somewhere in the middle, uh, more
often with adverse risks, cyto and P53, unfortunately, compared to IDH2.
And then, you know, how do we treat these patients?
So this is an analysis.
This is kind of more of an MD Anderson specific where we give venetoclax with intensive chemotherapy.
And just to highlight that, you know, these are younger patients that are getting intensive
chemotherapy.
We add venetoclax, IDH2 mutation.
The IDH2 mutated patients are that light blue curve along the top.
They do particularly well.
For some reason, the IDH1 mutated patients tend not to do as well.
This is a small analysis, but, you know, they're some of the least, um, likely to stay in a
remission with intensive chemo.
Then just highlighting the fact that we say IDH mutations are so ven sensitive, but it
really, I think is overrepresented by the IDH2 mutated patients.
Um, and this just highlights further that if you have an IDH1 mutation, you got intensive
chemo then.
You're going to do especially well if you transition to a transplant, whereas the IDH2
mutated patients really seem to be more like NPM1.
You may be cured with intensive chemo alone without the need to proceed to transplant.
Um, what else can you do for younger patients getting intensive chemo?
Certainly you can add the IDH inhibitors, right?
Ivocidinib, N-acidinib.
This is a study that was reported and published over five years ago now, um, where, you know,
when you look at the IDH1, they're not, they look to be doing particularly well.
Especially when you consider a third or secondary AML.
The median age here is in the mid third, mid sixties.
So maybe again, highlighting the fact that adding an IDH1 in particular may be of benefit.
IDH2s do well in general, but not quite as well.
And then there was a follow-up at ASH that Eitan presented with long-term follow-up.
Again, highlighting this kind of relatively flat curve.
Patients seem to be doing well staying in remission.
Um, and, um, and half of those patients did undergo stem cell transplant.
Um, which I think is also important to remember.
So just to kind of serve as the background to the Hovon AMLSG study, which has been enrolling, um, and completed enrollment in 2023 and 2024.
And I, I don't know for sure.
I'm not involved in this, but I, I think, um, this may be coming to a, uh, summer meeting near us where we may hear some of these initial results.
Um, but to talk then about triplets, right?
We're talking all the more about triplet.
We're talking about regimens these days using an HMA, using venetoclax and adding a targeted therapy, um, adding the IDH inhibitors were some of the earliest triplets.
And we now have recently reported on the first 60 newly diagnosed patients getting a triplet with either aza, ven, ivo, or oral decitabine, venetoclax, and ivo, or ena.
Um, it's a busy slide, but just to highlight the fact that we're really not seeing early mortality.
We're not seeing early toxicity.
IDH inhibitors are pretty easy to add to HMA venue.
We don't have a lot of Cytopenias.
You'll notice about 22% of the population has a co-occurring NPM1 mutation.
You are flip three because we tend to prioritize flip three triplets if they have flip three mutations.
Um, and 7% had a P53 mutation.
Almost everyone responded.
The first bar graph shows overall response rate over 90% for both IDH1 and IDH2.
Um, the treated secondary AML patients were allowed on the oral decitabine study.
Many of the AML patients have had a prior HMA, many have had prior venetoclax, and so when you take those patients and analyze them separately, you look at the non-treated secondary AML patients, the response rate is 100%, um, with pretty impressive, you know, two-year overall survival.
This is still a relatively early study, and we're following these patients up.
Um, but, you know, one of the questions that Vinay was asking me is, like, let's talk about the co-occurring mutations along with the IDH mutations.
So, let's talk about the co-occurring mutations along with the IDH mutations.
So, that's the first column, right?
You can see survival, event-free survival, duration of remission, and NPM1 mutated patients do well, but the ones that aren't NPM1 mutated patients do well also.
KRAS and NRAS in these triplet regimens isn't statistically significant.
With more patients and more follow-up, probably will be.
You know, you do start to see a splaying of EFS, and certainly P53, right?
Those few patients with P53, they respond, but then they relapse.
So, this, unfortunately, is not going to be the cure-all for that.
Um, what's interesting about the mutations that relapse, and this is kind of a busy slide, but what yellow are emerging mutations, and purple is if they, it was there at the beginning, and then you lost it.
So, of the six IDH1 mutated patients that have relapsed on this study to date, only one had a detectable IDH1 when they relapsed.
For the IDH2, four relapsed, two of them persisted, two didn't.
So, you're actually starting to see this looks to be very effective at eradicating.
That IDH1 clone.
Um, and relapses tend to be IDH wild type.
Um, but what they do relapse with tends to be a little bit, uh, you know, there's not a clear pattern.
You see some, some differentiating mutations like SWAMP1 and CBP-alpha.
You do see some signaling mutations.
Um, but you don't see that switch, right?
The IDH1 to the IDH2 or vice versa.
And we're not seeing kind of those site mutations kind of at the enzymatic, uh, binding site.
So, just to remember, when you're using monotherapy, the IDH inhibitors, you,
you tend to have those second site mutations kind of preventing drug from binding.
You could have that isoform switching IDH1 flips to IDH2.
We're not seeing either of those when we're doing triplets.
We tend to see that the non-2HG related, either the kind of transcription mutations,
reinstituting the, the block and differentiation or these signal mutations.
Um, there is now a, uh, European study of AZA-IVO as the background,
plus minus venetoclax to see if indeed adding a triplet to IDH1 mutated patients
will be as what we hope as effective and tolerable as what we've seen thus far at our institution.
Um, and just one really quick, um, it's, it's, you know, a whole talk in and of itself,
but Paresh Vyas, um, in Oxford looked at all of our kind of resistant and relapsing and
responding samples and was able to identify by doing single-cell and RNA-seq on, um, on
samples on our triplet trial that you can actually predict who's going to relapse or not within the
first three cycles. So if you have kind of this small residual, um, immunophenotypic leukemic
population in the LSC fraction, those patients were destined to relapse. It often happens six
to 12 months later, but it would happen. Whereas if you didn't see that, those patients were,
seemed to be effectively cured. So you probably are going to be able to identify who is prone or
destined to relapse or not once we get some of these more fancy analytics able to be done in
real time. And so with that, I will close. You don't need to,
read my conclusions, and I will.